you're you're an admirer of Eric Norman
and all you yeah and that's the Norman
connection is really interesting cuz I
think he's a bloody genius I really like
the great mother is a great book and I'm
really a great warning that book and
also the origins and history of
consciousness yeah that's so interesting
I read an essay that you wrote yes it's
always been staggering to me that that
book hasn't had the impact that it
should have had I mean um self in the
preface to that book wrote that that was
the book that he wished that he would
have written it's very much associated
with young symbols of transformation and
it was a major influence on my book maps
of meaning which was an attempt to
outline the universal archetypes that
that are portraying the kind of
religious structures that you that you
put forward but the thing that I really
see happening and you can tell me what
you think about this in annoyance book
consciousness which is masculine
symbolically masculine for a variety of
reasons is is viewed as rising up
against the countervailing force of
tragedy from an underlying feminine
symbolically feminine unconsciousness
right and it's something that can always
be pulled back into that unconsciousness
that would be the microcosm of that
would be the Freudian eatable mother
family allele dynamic where the mother
was so over protective and
all-encompassing that she interferes
with the development of the competence
not only of her sons but also of her
daughters of her children in general and
it seems to me that that's the dynamic
that's being played out in our society
right now is that there's this and it's
it's related in some way that I don't
understand to this to this insistence
that all forms of masculine Authority
are nothing but tyrannical power so the
symbolic representation is tyrannical
father with no appreciation for the
benevolent father and benevolent mother
with no appreciation whatsoever for the
tyrannical mother right and that's that
and because I thought of ideologies as
fragmentary mythologies that's where
they get their archetypal and
psychological power right and so in a
balanced representation you have the
terrible mother and the great mother as
Norman laid out so nicely and you have
the terrible father and the great father
so that's the fact that culture mangles
you
to death well it's also promoting you in
developing you you have to see that as
balanced and then you have the heroic
and adversarial individual but in the
postmodern world and this seems to be
something that's increasingly seeping
out into the culture at large you have
nothing but the tyrannical father
nothing but the destructive force of
masculine consciousness and nothing but
the benevolent benevolent great mother
and it's a it's an appalling ideology
and it seems to me that it's sucking the
vitality which is exactly what you would
expect symbolically it's sucking the
vitality of our culture you see that
with the increasing demolition of of
young men and not only young men in
terms of their academic performance
which like they're falling way behind in
elementary school way behind in junior
high and bailing out of the universities
like mad